en la puerta de mi visión asesinaron a
un presidente
ahora
imagínense que están caminando por esa
calle saben qué indicación tendrían de
esto
absolutamente ninguna es más si ustedes
estuvieran caminado por esa calle ven
algo muy parecido a esto
qué es la puerta la persiana
y bueno ni siquiera se fijaría en eso
seguirían de largo y no lo cuestionaría
ahora vamos a una situación alternativa
ya que la que ustedes están caminando
por la plaza independencia llegan al
centro y se encuentran al centro de
plasencia se encuentran con este
monumento acá
qué bueno este momento artigas todos
deben conocer
y dígame los que pasan por ahí seguido
que debe haber algunos cuando pasan
cuando lo ven este monumento alguna
conexión hacen alguna reflexión tienen
que tener sobre bueno por lo menos el
valor histórico por lo menos piensan ahí
está el profesor montado en su caballo
algo piensan
eso no pasa cuando cruzan la calle de mi
liceo y ven la puerta eso significa que
el monumento es de alguna manera más
valioso más valioso que esa puerta bueno
por más que podrían intentar yo que sé
comparar los logros de don josé gervasio
con los del ex presidente verán zio
flores este no es el punto que estoy
intentando usar
el monumento es conocido por que la
gente es expuesta y educada en este
aspecto de la cultura
qué genial porque bueno todo tema podría
nombrar muchos lugares además de este
monumento que consideran culturales si
no estoy diciendo que la gente se
completamente inculta
pero
si por cada uno de estos llamémosle
lugares históricos
en lo que pasó algo bueno por ello los
conocen no tenemos otro lugar no
histórico como es la puerta de mi liceo
en lo asesinaron a un presidente
piénsenlo
y el medio raro no
yo digo imagínense lo como si fuera yo
que es el océano
levante la mano quien sabe lo que es eso
muy bien todos creen conocer y entender
el océano por lo menos básicamente pero
sin embargo tan sólo un 5% del océano ha
sido explorado hasta ahora
y yo comparo la cultura más bien comparo
nuestro conocimiento acerca a nuestra
cultura con este océano pero me atrevo a
decir que incluso menos de un 5% es lo
que conocemos nuestra cultura
repito no estoy diciendo que la gente
sea completamente inculta pero sin duda
hay un alto rango de ignorancia respecto
a la cultural
ahora
no estará acá para hacerlo sentirse como
burros no es mi intención y más vengo
con una solución a esta ignorancia pero
primero creo que tendríamos que
identificar el problema
yo creo que el problema
viene que nosotros vemos lugares como
este no sólo de artigas de una manera
distinta la que vemos un abad usa
cualquiera
yo con mi liceo hago vías culturales por
la ciudad vieja o sea recorridos
y siempre apuntamos con estos recorridos
a que tengan un toque no convencional a
salir de lo ordinario
siempre intentamos que sin importar si
hablamos del lugar más conocido del
mundo eso no está la ciudad vieja pero
bueno o del bar de la esquina
siempre intentamos que el valor que le
transmitimos a nuestros guiados sea algo
que pueda trascender trascender lo que
se ve a simple vista
en otras palabras tomamos las baldosas
decía vieja
se las vendemos a ustedes como si
estuvieran hechas de chocolate
bien
el proyecto surgió hace años y se viene
manteniendo al principio del socom algo
medio institucional en el que los chicos
de ministerios y lo hacíamos
el chico de primaria después fue
creciendo la gente del barrio se empezó
a interesar fue la gente todo el
departamento chicos del interior incluso
y hace poco le hicimos un recorrido a
unos muchachos que venían de eeuu
piénsenlo de otro país evidentemente
nuestro proyecto funciona la gente se
interesa
pero como que hacemos esto
bueno yo creo que es muy simple en
realidad
la intención que tenemos siempre
es
adoptar perspectivas que podamos
transmitirlo después a nuestros guiados
lo que hacemos es pensar la cultura está
acá en cada bloque de cemento solo
tenemos que intentar intentar conocer y
entender
para luego poder acceder a esa cultura y
transmitirse a los guiados porque
nosotros decimos la ciudad vieja
pero en realidad cualquier lugar es una
mina de oro cultural sólo hay que salir
ahí salir ahí por esa conocer porque
conocer si va que entendamos y entender
lleva a que apreciemos y le apreciar ya
que nos enamoremos y yo amo a mi barrio
así que
ahora cuando salgan a la calle
por el primer edificio que pasen
pregúntense si no será ahí donde habrán
asesinado algún presidente muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]